(audience cheering)
- Have a seat.
- Hang on, I just want to visit
with Jane for a little bit.
If that's okay.
- [Kelly] Okay fine.
I get it, I get it.
- So I haven't you
since the last Hollywood
- How is your family?
- Everybody,
Hollywood Game Night.
- I know all of us have been, I know.
That's what you need.
- The funnest game show ever.
- [Jane] Oh good,
- [Kelly] I know.
- Ever.
- Well wait, we've all been
on Hollywood Game Night, a lot of us here,
but actually, a few of y'all have been
on Dancing with the Stars
as well.
- Give it up.
(audience cheers and drowns out talking)
- I've given up dancing,
is that what you mean?
- Yeah, that too.
- What was that like?
Like being on that show?
- I don't think
people understand how brutal that show is.
- Oh no, it looks like
fat camp.
- [Jane] It was brutal,
yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, to me.
(audience hollers)
- You better get you some
of that sleeveless number.
- God forbid they do
the picture of the dance
when I was in a tuxedo, no.
- No, we want to embarrass you.
- And they'll vouch for this,
is that the thing that was the weirdest
for me was if you got moved forward,
there was no, "I'll see
you in a couple days."
it was the next morning,
you were back in this dance hall.
I figured out when I left that show,
when I got eliminated in the finals,
that I had danced six hours a day,
seven days a week for 13 weeks.
- [Jane] Wow.
(audience whoops)
- [Kelly] Were you in incredible shape?
- No, no.
(audience laughs)
- You were sore, your toes were sore.
- And I was, I won't say my age,
but it was in the high 50s when I did it.
Men my age, see they're young.
Men my age aren't designed
to dance six hours a day,
seven days a week for 13 weeks.
We're designed to dance once a year,
drunk at a wedding.
(audience laughs and claps)
- Jane, would you ever do dancing
with the stars?
- I would not.
If you hear that I'm doing
Dancing with the Stars,
you know there's something
really wrong with me.
Absolutely not, I can't, I hate to dance.
I hate people telling
me how to move my body
because I can't do it.
- I feel like you would be so,
not on the show, but like
so much fun.
- She would do it.
- I'd be a big joke, that's what I'd be.
- I want to go
dancing with you.
- [Bill] What do you
think I was?
- I'd be the Bill Engvall of it.
- That was the best part of it
because I kept getting moved forward,
and what I always think is funny is,
if you go back and google the dances,
don't even watch the dance,
just go to when they call the scores out,
and look at the judges' face.
Every time we got moved forward,
they had this look, like,
"How is he still here?"
(audience laughs)
- But it's fan voted.
- It's fan voted.
And I had a blast.
Emma, little Emma Slater was my partner,
and I would never, ever do it again.
(audience laughs)
- [Jane] But God bless
you for doing it, though,
that is just amazing.
- In 13 weeks, I tore my
groin, pulled my hamstring,
and had to have my knee replaced.
- [Jane] Wow.
- And I say no sir to that.
- [Bill] No ma'am.
- Nope, nope.
So you're touring, though,
and your doing Last Man
Standing with Tim Allen.
That show is hilarious.
- Great,
we have so much fun with it.
- Yeah, are you having such a good time?
Great cast?
- Yeah, play a character
called Reverend Paul that's kinda
become a reoccurring character,
and he's, Revered Paul's
probably the only guy
that can say things to Mike Baxter
that nobody else can say
because he's in the clergy.
But it's been interesting.
It's like kind of with
Dancing with the Stars,
I'm on the road now, people are like,
"Hey, do another Last Man Standing."
It's amazing the popularity of the show,
but it's a great show.
- It's a great show.
- So hopefully they'll give me a lot more.
(audience claps)